[Music]
foreign
are part of the millions of young people
out of work in China in May the youth
unemployment rate hit a new high nearly
four times the national level that's
roughly 6 million people between the
ages of 16 and 24 who are unemployed and
there are signs it could get even worse
in coming months as millions of new
graduates enter the labor market over
the summer high unemployment not only
affects confidence in the economy it
also risks stoking social
dissatisfaction ultimately it could
cause social instability if young people
grow more angry and frustrated about
their lack of opportunities
[Music]
after China suddenly reopened its
economy initially triggering a massive
wave of covert infections expectations
were high that its consumers would
eventually drive a strong economic
rebound but those hopes are fading
with Shoppers pulling back and exports
and foreign investment falling and most
troubling more young people in China's
towns and cities out of work
during the lockdown period the sector
that suffered disproportionately were
the small and medium-sized Enterprises
that employ 70 to 80 percent of people
in China we had the assault on the
technology and tutoring sectors and
these are sectors which provided a lot
of jobs for young graduates in
particular the tutoring sector which was
eliminated almost overnight another
important reason is the mismatch between
the white colored jobs the young
graduates would like to do and the need
for blue color workers
there's a lot at stake when it comes to
correcting these imbalances given how
important the youth population is to
China's economy Rising joblessness means
less income for young people of course
that means less spending on things like
education travel mobile phones which
means less economic outputs young people
are important to consumers in the
economy especially in the luxury Market
frustrated by mounting uncertainties
young people are turning to different
career paths to secure an income we've
seen an uptick in people interested in
taking the Civil Service examinations in
pursuit of this so-called iron rice bowl
or job security there have also been new
additions to the lexicons such as lying
Flats where young people are opting out
of the rat race or an escalation of that
in letting it rot when you Embrace sort
of giving up in the face of what seems
like impossible odds and of course
there's also the study of running which
became popular during covid in people
pursuing opportunities abroad some are
settling of course for lower paying jobs
just so they can get the Social Security
and health benefits
foreign
China's government has responded with
several policies to boost hiring they
have made a lot of tax breaks and
subsidies to both private and
state-owned companies to expand the
internship opportunities they have
impressed upon local governments to hire
as many young people as possible and
also they have come up with another
solution that is not necessarily
welcomed by the youngsters which is to
send or encourage the relocation of
graduates to rural areas in China
ultimately job creation will depend on
economic growth especially in the
services sector where young people tend
to dominate private businesses will need
to feel more confident about growth
prospects before they invest and expand
their workforces however there are many
reasons for caution for example slowing
Global growth Rising U.S China tensions
especially in technology as well as
present seizing Things Push for common
Prosperity as well as more party control
over the economy
[Music]